Well,
I don't think it necessarily has value
for everyone then.
I'm not one of these people.
He said you should get on twitter and
everybody should have a twitter account.
I know,
I can tell you what's interesting about
it for me is,
um,
people can elect to follow writers and
thinkers and speakers they are
interested in and you can elect to
follow the back or not.
And so for me it's,
it's a great way to build a network of
people who are interested in my work,
friends of my ideas.
So that's what the people who follow me
on twitter or are there friends of my
ideas and I can talk to them through
this network as they listened to me,
but also a lot of other people at the
same time.
So I have a small part in their feed.
Um,
which is fine because I'm one of many
voices at listening to.
So that's what twitter is.
It's your own network of people who
follow what you do and say,
okay,
well I'm learning twitter.
I'm in my first few months doing it.
And so I'm doing lots of things that
just help me understand,
um,
the form and a lot of them are just,
probes.
They're just,
um,
uh,
playing around 10 green as it were with
something new.
Um,
but I use it the way other people do in
that.
Um,
the people I follow are constantly
posting links and ideas about stuff that
I want to keep up with.
Um,
when I find something that I think would
interest the kind of people who read my
blog or who follow my arguments,
I post it here something new.
I post questions to my followers,
I push out news of my work as it,
um,
up here is around the web.
And I also get a kind of a real time
reaction to things going on in the news
that really interests me,
especially in the media is,
and in the whole realm of alternative
media,
new media.
These are things that I follow with a
passion.
And so it's keeping me in touch.
It's filtering the web for me.
It's,
um,
reading the newspaper for me.
And it's also a group of people who I
trust with my ideas,
both in finished form and in the kind of
tentative grope me that you do when
you're trying to figure out your
reaction to things like the saddleback
forum where Mccain and Obama appeared in
last week.
Right.
Uh,
and so it's,
it's part of living in a world of
information with really expert guides.
That's twitter for me.